Ірландія. У цьому ідилічному куточку Європи
триває робота над удосконаленням
основ демократії. Що це означає, може пояснити
Фінбарр О‘Браєн. Він поштар і йому 62 роки.
Для нього політики завжди були кимось там, згори…
Я не мав жодного поняття про політику
І нуль інтересу. Аж поки мене не запитали,
чи хотів би я бути членом громадських зборів.
Громадські збори визначають майбутнє Ірландії.
Три роки тому, приміром, О‘Браєн брав участь
у голосуванні щодо легалізації одностатевих шлюбів.
Ви вже, мабуть, чули про священиків-педофілів?
Так-от я сам пережив це в дитинстві.
Відколи це сталося, я думав:
гомосексуали всі однакові – брутальні. Байдуже,
педофіли, геї чи лесбійки. Всі однакові.
Я ненавидів їх та зневажав.
Ось у цьому готелі поблизу Дубліна
вже кілька років відбувається
цей громадсько-демократичний експеримент.
Тут засідають члени Громадських зборів.
Фінбарр був у складі перших - у 2014 році.
Особливість експерименту: 99 ірландців
упродовж року беруть політику у свої руки.
Це цілком звичайні громадяни: молоді, старі,
з вищою освітою, селяни, навіть вишибали в кафе.
Усіх обирають за принципом жереба.
На цих зборах ідеться про майбутні пенсії.
Демонструють статистику, заслуховують експертів.
Усе транслюється наживо в інтернеті.
Економічна криза була величезним ударом
для Ірландії. На вулицях відчувався гнів громадян.
Винними у кризі вважали політиків.
Тому в народі з’явилося спільне бажання
випробувати щось нове. Зокрема, залучити
громадян до дебатів про майбутнє Ірландії.
Вони голосують і передають свої рекомендації
урядові. Професійні політики не мусять обов’язково
дотримуватися рішення громадськості, але це -
дуже сильний сигнал.
Приміром, легалізація одностатевих шлюбів.
Здавалося, що в Ірландії це неможливо собі уявити.
Занадто консервативне населення, занадто сильна
церква. Тим не менше, на громадських зборах
три роки тому предметно обговорили цю табуйовану
тему. І лише завдяки цьому Фінбарр О‘Браєн змінив
свою думку.
Це стало для мене важливим уроком,
що гомосексуали - теж нормальні люди. Вони нічого
лихого дітям не заподіюють. Тож я підвівся
на громадських зборах і заявив, що я - за одностатеві шлюби.
Так сказала більшість на Громадських зборах.
Це голосування переросло у референдум.
На ньому католицька Ірландія сказала «так»
одностатевим шлюбам.
Можливість висловити свою думку і вплинути
на політику. Для Фінбарра це найліпше,
що могло трапитися в житті.
На громадських зборах сидять звичайні люди.
Ми – громадяни і наша думка важлива.
І головне - до неї дослухаються.
Він переконаний, що політикам слід наважитись і
віддати частину влади в руки громадян.